everybody who plays Jeopardy always says
the secret to winning Jeopardy of course
you got to know your stuff and it's not
so much uh you know uh the knowledge but
also knowing how to work the buzzer
right buzzer's huge and you know you
watch the show at home and you see
people flailing away on this thing like
idiots and you're like what is wrong
with you but it's tough because Gary
described to me because he's done the
Celebrity Jeopardy right you got the if
you have three lights on the sides that
you can see off camera and there's a
white light a red light of this light
when the white light goes on you can
buzz in so if you start buzzing in
before yeah you're not getting in an
even worse you know you're going to get
locked out for like a fraction of a
second so if coming in too early is like
as bad as coming in too late and people
that's what people do they Buzz too
early you won 3.1 million something like
that isn't that amazing it's crazy right
would you sit at home and play Jeopardy
and and sort of say wow I'm getting
every one of these well sure but
everybody's good on their couch right
you know no I'm not I'm not good on my
couch I'm an idiot I watch
know anything that's going on were you
were you of a superior intellect was
your IQ ever measured no but you know I
was good in school I was the kind of kid
that you know and I was you know raised
in the 80s when Trivial Pursuit was very
big so I grew up on that kind of stuff
and I I always loved you know I would
love those facts exactly I would skip
school to watch game shows like I was a
huge nerd as a kid so when you make 3.1
million and uh Jeopardy do you quit
working you know a traditional job do
you say hey I've got enough money I
don't need to work anymore well I gotta
you know I got an offer to write a book
and and that's what I'd always wanted to
do I was like an English major in school
who figured I'll never make a living at
this I better learn how to like you know
write computer programs too so I got
into computers right and uh and I sucked
at it I didn't like it and so when
somebody offered me a book I was like
wow maybe you know maybe there is a
career in this and like eight years
later I'm still doing it wow oh that's
wonderful so uh you've been able to not
have a traditional job because of
Jeopardy yeah and these game shows it's
really remarkable it's weird why did you
not win Jeopardy the there was a
Tournament of Champions you came in
second I did were you shocked I mean
because you were the longest running
winner I think I was but you know
there's a ton of guys who are really
good I I came on right when they had
changed the release after five days they
would give you a car and kick you off
right right which was stupid right they
should let these guys The Great Well I
know I got reinvigorated with Jeopardy
when you were on because it was like wow
I heard about this guy who kept winning
week after week it was you had to watch
the streak yeah right right I'm sure
most people were rooting against me but
you know it's the same thing people are
watching yeah yeah uh so there are a ton
of guys that are just as good and one of
these guys came back and it was just the
buzzer he was he was faster than me he
was better at the buzzer and he knew his
stuff for sure how long was your run on
Jeopardy like 75 games so it was almost
six months of Jeopardy time removed from
the game or does he sort of hang he
doesn't hang with you it sort of he
comes on set does the game and then he
leaves he's not allowed to you know
because of all the scandals in the 50s
it's like still a felony in this country
to rig a game show so you're not allowed
to hang out with anybody who knows the
answers and that includes Trebek I
remember one time they took me back to
change my tie at Amir the tie was you
know moireing on camera or whatever so I
go back to change my time they take me
to the same mirror that Trebek uses and
people freak out he can't be back there
you know it's like it's like Trump
pick's not even there it's like a
lockdown alarms are going off and you
might talk to Trebek's image that was
just in America the mirror will talk let
me get the straight so the game show
made you a millionaire and do you invest
this money now that you have the three
you don't have 3.1 you have to pay taxes
and all that but do you invest this
money and has it grown I would imagine
maybe you're some sort of Genius
investor too where else does your Genius
come out no I haven't written some
business I mean all this money was
before the economy crashed so I see I
don't think I have it all anymore but
yeah it's pretty boring we invested for
you know the kids college and retirement
and stuff like that right it's not like
I lost it all on the one hand of
blackjack or strippers but I bet a lot
of people think you're like this way
richer than you really are yeah it's not
it's not like you know Screw you money
you know I I can't go live on an island
somewhere so you even say you're not a
genius you weren't the most BR you
weren't valedictorian of your school no
but it was just this sort of trivia
knowledge that you word but I think you
go beyond trivia because you know you're
doing like geography that's a little
more intense you're doing history that's
a little more intense than just sort of
general trivia it seems you're way more
educated and way more aware than the
average trivia guy well the thing about
it you know when you're this kind of
person it's you know your knowledge
might be a mile wide but it's like an
inch deep you know you know you know a
little bit about a lot of things but
it's really a little bit you know you
and the other thing about Jeopardy is
you're only buzzing in on what you know
you're not demanded to answer questions
you don't know that's right is that
exactly true because I would think in
order to buzz in you've got to sort of
think you you got to think so fast that
you kind of think you have an idea of
the answer and sometimes you come up
with the answer after you buzz in does
that make sense no at all it's true that
you you know you gotta you gotta wait
till the question's been read to buzz
but it's true that I have had the the
situation of no you know some part of
your brain knows that you know it so you
buzz and then while Alex is staring at
you you got a few seconds to dig it out
foreign